Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson's show on Fox News is a
major catalyst of disinformation. And his ratings
are really good. So what is he doing now? He's
going further down the conspiracy rabbit hole to
the point that you can't even understand what he's
saying. This is a really common characteristic
among charlatans among pseudoscience purveyors
and others at a certain point. The things they
say no longer makes sense to anyone, even their
followers. But that's OK because their followers
assume it must make sense to someone. So I'm going
to just go with it. If you look back at Jim Jones
from the People's Temple, this is the guy who got
his followers to drink cyanide laced Kool-Aid and
kill themselves. His so-called teachings over time
would make less and less sense to his followers,
and some of them would be sort of conflicted. But
the fact that it made no sense became a source of
his power. He must really be telling us some high
level stuff here. I had the good sense to start
following him. I'm not understanding what he's
saying, but it must really be important stuff.
Alex Jones His conspiracy theories became and have
become increasingly unintelligible. So anyway,
here is basically an Alex Jones type
conspiracy theory from Tucker Carlson
related to the White House looking set that
the Biden administration used for Joe Biden's
third vaccine dose. Look at all of the things
that Tucker Carlson infers from the fact that
the White House has like a set that looks like
one room from the White House. Take a look at this
Speaker 3: and keep them informed
of international incidents. Instead,
they are in some cases freelancing to crush anyone
who opposes their power. Mike Flynn, for example,
he was briefly the national security adviser in
the Trump administration. What we learned from the
destruction of Mike Flynn really was that sure,
you can elect Donald Trump president, but does he
really run the executive branch of government?
Speaker 1: Sorry. And I'm realizing I started
this too late. We're getting to
Mike Flynn in a moment, but let's
let's pick it up at the beginning. Take a look at
Speaker 3: the latest example. These are pictures
of a fake White House set to the Biden
administration has for some reason constructed
across the street from the actual White House.
It's in an auditorium at the Eisenhower Executive
Office Building. Why go to the trouble?
They already have a White House? Well,
Stephen Miller spent the last four years
in the White House as an adviser to Trump,
and here's his explanation for it because he
would now quote the reason Biden uses this
bizarre virtual set for televised meetings and not
an actual room like the East Room, the Cabinet,
the Oval, the Roosevelt Room, etc. A
lot of rooms. The reason he does this
is because it allows him to read a script
directly from a face on monitor and without
teleprompter glass that can be seen on camera.
Speaker 1: So this is actually quite silly because
if that was the concern, you could just do that by
setting up a different camera angle in any of the
rooms Tucker mentioned. Like even at its at its
core, it doesn't even pass the sniff test. Oh.
Speaker 3: Now, we can't verify that that's
true, but it certainly sounds right. Well,
maybe Joe Biden can't speak from the Oval
Office because he's not sure what to say,
so he has to read it all here. So that raises a
much deeper question. The question is not is Joe
Biden mentally impaired? Obviously, he is. And
again, we're not going to gloat over it. But a
much more important question for the rest of us is
if he's not running the government, then who is?
That's a real question. Clearly, the FBI,
the DOJ and the military already acting
independently of the elected president of the
United States, as you just saw, they don't even
keep them informed of international incidents.
Instead, they are in some cases freelancing
to crush anyone who opposes their power. OK, so
Speaker 1: it's starting to get very, very
conspiratorial. And then just to show you like
how far this all goes, here's one one more example
Here's Tucker's preview of an interview with
Trump's former national security adviser,
Michael Flynn, and he's talking
about deep state conspiracy theories.
Speaker 3: Began with a long interview
with Mike Flynn. It's coming out Monday,
and he told us what is really obvious to
everyone who watches an unelected group within
Washington effectively runs the country without
reference to voters. Here's his assessment.
Speaker 2: We have two separate governments. We
have the one that actually gets elected and goes
into office. And then you have a government inside
of Washington, D.C. that operates under no rules,
no authorities other than their
own or whoever in charge of
Speaker 3: their hands like that
government was still controlled by Barack
Speaker 2: Obama. Yeah, and I would
say that that's that, to a degree,
is what we're operating with today.
Speaker 3: By the way, Mike Flynn is
not some internet celebrity or conservative
activist, he was a three star general, yeah,
Speaker 1: who became a complete and
total lunatic once he started working
for Trump or before. And we just didn't notice
Speaker 3: an intelligence agency as the number
two guy for all American intelligence. He spent
his entire life working in the federal government
and succeeding at that. So he knows what he's
talking about. He is a reliable guide to how
the government actually works. Our whole
conversation with Mike Flynn, by the way,
Speaker 1: he could not be a less reliable
guide as to how the government works. Mike Flynn
seems to have had something happen that has made
him completely delusional about even the basic
facts of how the world works. So this is a really
they're basically talking about like an Obama run
deep state of some kind. And this has many, many
iterations. This is a family of conspiracies,
much studied significant amount of literature
on it. Sometimes it's called deep state. It's a
shadow government of some kind. Sometimes you call
it the deep state. Sometimes it's the Freemasons.
Sometimes it's the Jews. Sometimes it's the
Vatican could be the trilateral commission,
the Illuminati, the build, the bergs. It's
it's there's a bunch of versions of it. And
this seems to be what Tucker Carlson's audience
now wants. So when we talk about OANN and Newsmax
are well beyond Fox News in terms of what they're
willing to put on there. Yeah, it's true in a way.
And yet look at what's happening on Tucker's show
lately. And then in addition, when we say, well,
you've got MSNBC, which is left and Fox News,
which is right. Sure, they're both corporate media
networks with different editorial bents, but there
is nothing on MSNBC that is equivalent to this.
So this seems to be what Tucker's audience
wants, and Fox News seems to be gleefully
promoting it and signal boosting it and accepting
it. And again, I think it's because of the
financial incentives. Even though there have been
advertiser troubles with Tucker and his show. The
ratings are still there. And overall, this is a
good show for Fox News's business model. We're
going to have more of this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.